[Music]
there's this dude called on full blast
that is making some Super Cuts of the
best moments of Brendan Schaub and I
thought I'd just share with you it's
funny doing all these different things I
told you this one took a piss before I
stared at your dick you looked
doing all these different things I told
you this one took a piss before I stared
at your dick you looked you have a dick
on you dude
um
he was on Joe Rogan he was complimenting
his struggling his dick congrats man
congrats
oh there's four volumes of this one what
is Poppy
what up kids that was always my thing in
college at least and uh we did 550 which
is pretty easy now you'll put 600 on
let's go 600 dude I did six hundo I was
chalk just [ __ ] gorilla style it was
just me Fuzzy's telling you to be
careful that you don't [ __ ] up your back
there's no need to do it so I did 600
that's not 600 that's [ __ ] give me a
[ __ ] cut off jean shorts what do you
got on now they're short dogs right
they're short why does he oh Black Rifle
shirt why is why is
Brendan really leans into the gay stuff
like a lot you're not gonna be wrong we
make gay jokes all the time but like
he mentioned his dick like 10 times in
this new special it was only 20 minutes
long yeah it sounds like he doesn't have
much material also he's doing Theo Von's
bit now of like the what's up with them
shorts man yes oh my God man you look
like you're about to go uh catching
alligators or something man what's up I
you nailed them shoes bro what's up you
wearing like what are you waiting we
gonna go fishing later you wearing
waders for the river or something
brother that's that's actually a really
good feel man what's up with that shirt
bro you come coming out here looking
like like GI Jane or some [ __ ] bro
that's okay what's up you're even doing
field type jokes I really like it you're
all in I like it yeah my man Demi
Mooring it up in this [ __ ]
the only person that does a great
theological I love it that's on point I
love it because it's not that you're
doing it but even their Theo Vaughan
level jokes hey what's up with that
studio man looking like a tanning bed or
something what's up bro
a little short dude you get some quads
on you Siri these are regular
yeah thank God you have the talent to
back it up can you imagine if you were
like a hack like you couldn't like your
hour [ __ ] oh yeah could you imagine that
can you imagine close your eyes and
picture that
I've refused to believe that he's not
self-aware I refuse to believe it he
can't be like this right could you
imagine being a hack Royce I I
get together one yeah peanut butter and
jelly Daddy I gotta get that like
panicking but you're out to like moving
like a box you land at the punch but the
transitions you had three different
submissions and then finally get done
with a triangle without arms without
using your hands
that ain't blue you know you think of uh
Phil Davis right he's a stud yeah
complete freak out I've trained with
Phil freak like free do you train with
him the same way you hung out with Pete
Davidson your best friend like a
freaking yeah you know praying mantis
yeah and then you got uh Ruth right yeah
Ruth Savage as well yeah yeah he won a
lot of fights in Bellator and stuff won
a lot of fights in beldorf my mom's
balls deep in podcasts and listen to all
my podcast breaks up for this one and
she goes is that Mark Harley gonna be
with you I'm like
it's really funny is it because they
have the same hair
no they they have the same taste and
dress wear
it's also true and after all the
steroids the same natural test levels
yeah
if you brought him here
I mean yeah Mark he's on the road oh my
God you s you pretended like this was
natural did you see that he pretended
like it was natural but this is all
scripted he made his mom say it this
whole thing is exactly why people hate
Brenda white he made it seem like this
is his mom saying it to him watch
foreign
going to be with you I'm like
yeah he's yeah he's always on the road
with me Mom just goes oh I'm telling you
man if you brought him here
so it made it seem like this is a
natural conversation but it was was an
Instagram story for him hey Brett so is
Mark Harley gonna be there too with you
oh my god see see what I mean it was all
set up he's on the road oh my God he is
such a stud muffin Mark I have a broken
ankle right
if you were here and I didn't have this
broken ankle I'd be jumping all over you
boy
he makes his mom do this he made his mom
dude leave your mom out of your stuff
man I'm not going to [ __ ] on his mom by
the way because it's not her fault
unless she drinks unless unless she
drank when she was pregnant then it is
her fault but
um
look at it look at that face
I know I know what would you do that why
would you you want to make your mom a
[ __ ] why is that funny
oh okay he's the guy who has his funeral
fit for his grandma's [ __ ] funeral so
who knows with this guy but dude I
didn't realize how bad we're beating the
[ __ ] out all these little kids
ah okay and I don't know if you've seen
the punching Panda this she is a
punching Panda listen I'm always excited
when Angela fights but what I you know I
love Jiu Jitsu
um they're they're doing the first ever
uh flyweight submission grappling
championship against Mikey
mushushimi
mushumeshi
oh wow don't even try bro just just
don't more like mush or mouthy
dude I wouldn't even want to try to say
that name no [ __ ] that
foreign
well he's not a smart man shout out to
on full blast one word one word if you
guys want uh to subscribe you can I just
did uh the heat is pretty good stuff I'm
assuming it's a guy because it's funny
um
so I want to go into something else here
regarding these no these boys
they had one of the people I cannot wait
till I cannot wait until this [ __ ]
guy is 15 minutes are up but you've seen
him everywhere you know that liver King
guy
let's start with the liver this guy oh
God yeah I hate this guy so here's a too
long didn't read on this guy if you know
who he is this guy's liver King and
that's his name because he says that he
he only eats like raw liver in raw meat
like he won't he won't eat any sugar
nothing else that's all he eats and
that's his thing and then when asked
okay but yeah but you're clearly on
steroids he says he's not on steroids he
denies being on steroids yeah he's all
Natty bro yeah
this is a guy that like posted a really
long [ __ ] Soliloquy about 9 11 at the
9 11 Memorial and he didn't even put a
shirt on yeah
the guy that was outside Buckingham
Palace doing [ __ ] uh remember that he
was doing curls yep
deliver yeah let's not start with
Tabasco sauce all right let's go oh do
you put any sauce on them or like salt
or that's stupid well now I want to get
it and I want to get into why you don't
need fiber so they're gonna sit here and
they're gonna eat raw liver
vegetables are the enemy or what well
you guys grab a little piece I would
have this yeah you you eat that
can I please can I bring something up
here
I'm not saying this isn't gross because
it's gross but I'm telling you right now
Brandon is putting on
he's he's being as as the kids say extra
watch his face watch or what well you
guys grab a little piece he's such a bad
actor
you see
wait is he pretending to eat no he's
pretending that it's making him sick
damn he just goes for it all right
how is it chicken [ __ ] he's a chicken
[ __ ] he's not man no can I be honest at
the end of the day
that was way better I've never eaten
liver before
well yeah wait what
wait what what
I expected that was way better I've
never eaten liver before Oh that was
Mark Harley okay because it looks like
yeah I agree with you for a second I'm
like that's literally your name it's in
your name
well yeah
he's gonna throw up oh he's faking it
you're such a [ __ ] phony
you you're faking being sick because you
think it's funny
that's exactly my point either sit there
and be but everything with him is phony
he has to he's not naturally funny so
like you pointed out the Theo Von thing
is a great thing because he does copy
feel Von a lot Brennan is just an
amalgamation of every single LA's Comics
worst traits and he takes some fun
Health mayor yeah exactly like he tries
to be well Sasso he tries to be theovan
he takes stuff from from Chris to Leah
good dude I'm good I'm good no it's like
uh it's like sushi
you're having such a problem your eyes
are watering yeah I almost threw up yeah
it's very close but we got these little
cuts
um
the most testosterone
Laden meat I'm gonna answer that
question but the last thing we're going
to do is a piece of bone marrow damn it
okay so to to add to add here real quick
the reason I played this was for was for
a reason number one we have an
appearance from our from our good friend
feels threatened I'll tell you what big
a lion does and I just think I caught
something
oh oh come on Royce you're good at this
give me a second I have to frame by
frame it big gay lion
has big gay gyno
oh boy look at his nip you'll know this
this is called Rock before he had the
gyno surgery he hasn't look look at his
nipple he has gyno behind it you could
tell with that angle
um for sure 100 that's gyno and for
those that don't know gyno is is like
when you take too many steroids and you
don't do the right protocol your body
will basically start developing more
estrogen and your body will start
growing tits
think of meatloaf in Fight Club who said
[ __ ] Health where's my camera who's
that hell and he only has gyno on his
right tit look at how I'm glowing
because my Facebook oh you're glowing
all right your dad was in the CIA you're
definitely glowing I could see you from
space
would be if you ate that wrong
um
did you get the bone marrow now the
reason I brought this up right
liver King is a big get now everyone's
been trying to get the guy and obviously
he wasn't the fighter and the kid you
know what I just learned by doing a
little bit of just math
um the fighter and the kids studio is in
the same place that Mark Harley's little
studio is it's just a bunch of different
little sets right and you want to know
why Mark Carly on the cover of his
latest episode haters will say okay
Mark Harley
made it seem like the liver King was on
his show watch this
and I mean technically he was
and right off the Baton do liver King
meme of the week why don't you play that
clip there Casey oh let's take a look at
this one oh this is a good one
here's the thing
the name is liver King because liver is
King people are hurting and hating their
lives today I hate this guy haters
because they hate their own lives and
this is an expression a reflection I
actually love my life a pretty easy job
yeah I'm doing pretty well pretty good
pretty good little gig just hate you
guys of what they project to the outside
world right because people hate the
lives that they're living they're
suffering with depression anxiety
infertility autoimmune low energy
no there's a reason it's even funnier
it's full of Adventure excitement love
light and laughter that's why I'm the
CEO of the ancestral lifestyle to model
teach and preach this way so that we can
express our highest and most dominant
form so that we no longer have to suffer
never King out the liver king that's all
he did in the 40-minute episode was that
one minute thing but he made it seem
like it was on the whole episode and why
did he do it because he was in just
happened to be in the same Studios
fighter and the kid and he goes hey man
do me a favor
can you record something for my shows
that's what happened
that's what happened because
he needs some numbers because he ain't
getting them
one thing we know about Mark Harley is
he is a [ __ ] hanger on in the highest
degree